only with a lot of a lot of Hollywood is
just getting your material into people's
hands that can do something with it and
I think when you know you have something
good is when every single person that
reads it wants to be a part of it so
what happened was Michael was working he
was Robert Rodriguez's assistant on this
movie the faculty when we finished and
he didn't want to give the script to
Robert because he just didn't want it he
was practically living with him while
they were editing the movie and he just
didn't want to be that guy so he ended
up giving it to his boss on the movie
which was his post-production supervisor
she loved it wanted to be a part of it
she gave it to a producer's assistant
the producer's assistant gave it to this
producer the producer called me in
Atlanta when you know I had no idea what
was going on and said how would you guys
feel about Brad Pitt being the lead and
of course you know my heart's just like
what you know and you don't in
retrospect it's you can't believe how
impossible this chain of events is but a
week later Brad Pitt was attached to the
movie and that's how it sold so that's
my advice if you can get Brad Pitt
attached to your movie then it'll sell
man the odds have been long for a while
now we feel really fortunate to have
broken in and and when we did break in
five years later we we definitely
thought to ourselves thank God we broken
in 99 because it has gotten that much
harder but I just think the odds are
really really long anyway you have to
write something novel and great and and
that will stand out otherwise you're
just clutter that's why that's why I
feel like when we broke all of those
rules we we stood out you know for what
for whatever reason you can stand out in
a bad way if you had a bad story to go
with it but i think the guild gets
submitted to it some ungodly number of
scripts registered every year like
40,000 you know and that's just the
people that are registering the scripts
so you have to you have to get through
that you know process and be one of the
hundred that make it you know it's here
so I don't know I'm probably not the
best when this become right